[Music]
now to this developing story tonight a
fire at a las vegas apartment complex
left
22 people without a place to call home
this happened this afternoon off sahara
and maryland parkway
madison kimbrough has been covering this
story all day she joins us live tonight
and madison this isn't the first time
this complex has gone up in flames
sasha that is correct now in the past 8
news now has reported on the fact
that this apartment complex solaire west
apartment complex has experienced
several fires and tonight residents are
speaking out
as it happened again i just heard a lot
of commotion outside and
i look out the window and it's just a
lot of smoke residents like deira parker
who have lived at solaire west apartment
complex for several years
know all too well that today's incident
wasn't a first
but that doesn't make the situation any
less scary i've seen a couple of
buildings burned down since i've been
here yet
they can do better i feel like the cause
of the fire is still under investigation
but to give you a little back story
this apartment complex has caught fire
multiple times before
a couple times in 2017 and then in 2013
2012 and 2007. and we heard the loud
papa he jumped under my table
and that's when i went out to see what
it was and it was flames from the top to
the bottom and i grabbed and scooped him
up and
we have to go the fire started around
three sunday afternoon and clark county
fire department and the city of las
vegas fire and rescue
were on scene as it took 55 personnel to
assist with the damage
residents were asked to immediately
evacuate the area
i just got my kids and i got out of
there so my stepdaughter and my daughter
i got them and i'm glad they're okay
it's crazy you know what i'm saying
people got kids and
you know people got to be careful i was
just here maybe like 30 40 minutes ago
and then i went in my
house to play some fort so fortnite and
i came out
and i can't even get get through
now currently the red cross is assisting
22 people that have been displaced by
this fire
no pets were involved but the red cross
is helping
with of course clothes food and shelter
reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now